I'm not convinced that we're really very
well prepared at all to be perfectly
blunt I think there's two real problems
we've got as we go in the first is
really the technical side you know how
well developed is the UK's own
understanding of what it wants to
achieve in a lot of policy spaces which
are going to be important in the brexit
space then I think there's a second
aspect in which we may be not very well
prepared which is that I think that some
of the expectations which this
administration has encouraged people to
have about what can be delivered through
the brexit process are a little bit
unrealistic in terms of both what the
whole process can deliver and how
quickly we can work through and actually
you know be delivering the things that
we've said that we want in terms of you
know control of migration control of our
regulatory and legal structures you know
the idea that we're going to be able to
move directly to that as we leave at
some point in probably March 2019 or
perhaps a little after I think we need
to be pretty realistic about recognizing
that this is probably going to end up
being a more phased and gradual process
than much of the debate has suggested so
far
Theresa May arrives in Brussels with her
credibility shredded and no Commons
majority what will the EU negotiators
make of that I'm not convinced that the
e u--'s position had a lot of
flexibility built into it based on
whether Teresa may had a big majority or
not I think there is now a concern on
the EU side that the people on the other
side of the of the table as it were may
change or and may wish to revisit things
which had previously been agreed but I
don't think that it was ever the case
that a particularly big majority would
have really cut a lot of ice in terms of
changing how that you was viewing this
brexit negotiation process I think it
was always the case that the EU has a
clear view about what it wants to
achieve it knows the timelines it thinks
it's working - and ultimately I think
the EU was thought that while there was
some room to haggle at the margins the
UK was ultimately going to have to align
with its view of the process rather than
being able to impose it itself JPMorgan
employs 16,000 people in the UK but it's
chief strategist says the government's
stance is light on detail and
underestimate the size of the challenge
there are more than 30 regulatory
agencies where the UK currently relies
on the EU to set the framework which we
need to replace now as of the time of
writing there is not a well-defined
single document that I can go to that
maps out how we think those regulatory
agencies in the UK are going to work
what their general principles of
operation will be what our policy
objectives will be in each of those
fields and I think that really what that
exposes is that we are now in a
negotiation process with the EU where it
is perfectly reasonable for the EU to be
asking the UK well what is it you want
to do in those spaces
how are those systems in the UK going to
work what is the prototype for the
design and as I've said those things
just don't exist at
what we have was a white paper which was
less than 60 pages long and frankly did
not give a clear sense that the design
of those agencies was present thought
through and in place and it's in that
respect I think that when we go into the
negotiations
you know perhaps looking significantly
less well prepared than we might expect
to negotiating brexit is a huge
political and practical task so what
could the future look like when it's
finally completed I think people need to
realize that the it's in the services
sector that we're likely to see the
biggest changes through time and people
need to realise that for all of its
faults the European Union is the most
advanced and integrated services market
that we have in the world and it says we
leave the EU and as we negotiate a
future arrangement it's in the services
sector that the changes are likely to be
biggest and that doesn't just mean
financial services it also means sectors
like accountancy law broadcasting
consultancy these are all spaces where
the UK has developed a clear specialism
and does act to some extent as a
one-stop shop for people around the
world to get services within Europe and
I think it's in that space that the
biggest changes that come as a result
from brexit will come for the economy